as the book title says unseen body
so it tells
some kind of story of your life
so it does capture the decisions you've
made in your life the things you've done
that might be kind of secret
to that person and maybe to a few others
that knew him or her well
it's so fascinating so
what kind of things can it reveal like
what kind of choices in terms of the
injuries
the
the the catastrophic events
the
lifestyle choices of smoking and diet
and all those kinds of things what what
what
what can you see what kind of history
can you see about the human before you
so all those things you mentioned are
things you can see you can you know take
the skin for example right most things
that happen to us
leave a mark uh you know as i say a kind
of a story written in the language of
scar where it tells you injuries you've
had the same thing with animals you know
i've
i've seen deer hides that have marks
that look like they're made by maybe a
barbed wire fence something like that
you can tell
you know you sometimes it's conjecture
but you can sort of imagine what might
have happened to cause that perhaps you
know two bucks were fighting and one got
injured with an antler um and the same
with humans you know i have scars on my
body and when i
notice them i remember what happened you
know i
got a big cut on my hand when i was 13.
and it's still there and i
remember what happened uh you know every
time i look at it and so in that way
uh only i might know that story but
other people you know when they dissect
me and notice the same scars they can
kind of can fire their imagination as my
cadaver you know did for me they know
that there is a story there that's such
an interesting way that the skin does
tell a story
uh both tattoos and scars
right
given the fun you've had and some of the
damage you've done right and even when i
when i evaluate a patient i can use
scars
to help me make medical decisions so for
instance someone that comes in with
abdominal pain into the emergency room
you can see scars on their abdomen that
tell you about you know the past kind of
activities of a surgeon perhaps i know i
recognize the scars that are left when
someone has their gallbladder removed
the scars when someone has their
appendix removed when maybe when
someone's had a hysterectomy and that
can tell you
what it might be or what it isn't you
know if someone doesn't have an appendix
their abdominal pain is not appendicitis
end of story so in that way
i'm sort of looking at these the the
tracks or the footprints of past
surgeries to tell me what what might and
might not be the cause of this patient's
abdominal pain which is kind of my main
job
you